[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en Bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy abordamos las negociaciones del
pacto de migración que avanza lentamente
tres años después de que se presentara
la propuesta la Unión Europea será capaz
de gestionar una política que ha
dividido durante años los países lo
analizamos con nuestros invitados los
eurodiputados Jordi cañas del grupo
renovar Europa bienvenidos Jordi Hola
qué tal Muchas gracias por estar aquí y
con Javier zarzalejos del partido
popular europeo bienvenido Javier muchas
gracias muchas gracias a los dos la
gestión de la migración es el Eterno
debate en la Unión Europea existen ha
propuesto de un pacto migratorio que se
presentó hace tres años por parte de la
comisión europea pero que estaba
avanzando de forma muy lenta es
realmente posible
encontrar una solución hay suficiente
voluntad política Javier Bueno yo
siempre me manifestado digamos
moderadamente optimistas sobre las
posibilidades de que tengamos ese pacto
de inmigración y asilo en este en este
mandato parlamentario Es verdad que ha
avanzado muy lentamente por las
posiciones eran
realmente distantes pero yo creo que en
conjunto Las cosas se han ido acelerando
creo que el parlamento ha realizado una
una buena labor estamos a la espera de
que el consejo haga su parte pero yo
creo que tenemos una oportunidad Real de
lo que por otra parte creo que sería uno
de los grandes logros de esta
legislatura que por cierto ha sido una
legislatura complicada y una legislatura
muy sobresaliente en muchos temas pero
sin duda el pacto de inmigración ya ha
sido Debería ser y yo creo que tenemos
los elementos encima de la mesa para que
ese acuerdo se pueda se pueda dar y creo
que si se pierde esta oportunidad
tendremos serios problemas en
recuperarla en el futuro
Jordi con la guerra en Ucrania hemos
visto una solidaridad una solidaridad
sin precedentes con los refugiados
ucranianos de hecho se pudo activar una
cláusula para ofrecer el asilo
prácticamente de forma automática a
todos los ucranianos Pero esto no fue el
caso por ejemplo de otras personas que
han oído de otras guerras Como por
ejemplo la guerra de Siria existe un
doble rasero la política migratoria de
la Unión Europea
Sí sí es un doble rasero Yo creo que el
ejemplo sea evidente no es obvio porque
se pueden Y eso tiene una explicación
seguramente No pero si la pregunta es
hay un doble rasero Bueno nos ha tratado
igual sin duda Hay motivos y argumentos
que lo expliquen sí son razonables muy
razonables pero ante la pregunta de si
está todo cuando erasero yo creo que la
respuesta Es evidente
la situación probablemente desde el
impacto emocional que significó una
guerra en Europa y un movimiento de la
población que está oyendo de la guerra y
el nivel de conocimiento y de proximidad
pues hace uno que primero que las
opiniones públicas de los de los países
europeos no vean igual una situación que
fue muy similar o a la desidia por
ejemplo no donde millones de sirios
tuvieron que abandonar su país una
guerra terrorífica extremadamente cruel
y tuvieron que oír y sin embargo cuando
empezaron a llegar a Europa pues hubo se
pensaba que mejor se quedase en Turquía
no también Por cierto que cuando
hablamos a veces de migración y de asilo
de refugiados uno la judicial de
refugiado en teoría está hasta que llega
un país que tiene unas condiciones en
este caso pues Turquía Era ese país No
pero y en el nuestro en el caso de
Ucrania el país más próximo era Polonia
por lo tanto la la solidaridad se podía
entender bien porque ahí los refugiados
eran venían cruzaban una frontera y en
el caso de refugiados sitios por ejemplo
que pasaban a Turquía y Turquía con base
de las opiniones sale en un país donde
los derechos humanos se respetan donde
la libertad
perdían la condición de refugiados por
tanto esos refugiados cuando llegaban lo
que pasa que se explica poco Cuál es la
condición de refugiados pues dejaban de
serlo no Pero sinceramente yo creo que
unos políticos tenemos que dar
sinceramente y sobre todo con temas tan
importantes como este es que sí ha
habido una agilidad una rapidez y sobre
todo una un compromiso y una solidaridad
que no se ha dado en otras
circunstancias y que probablemente no se
dieran en otras circunstancias
entonces también hay un componente
racista no racista no repito es
importante proximidad o sea los
refugiados ucranianos conduían de la
guerra cruzaban una frontera como
refugiados huyendo de la guerra y
llegaban a Polonia
por lo tanto primero legalmente
si se puede hablar de legalidad cuando
uno tiene que salir desde su casa desde
su ciudad de su país porque porque la
está bombardeando y tiene riesgo de que
sus hijos mueran ojo de la legalidad
está muy bien Pero cualquiera de
nosotros fuéramos sirios de querrías ir
de ahí y estuviésemos en Sudán Ahora nos
querríamos ir porque estando tu vida la
de tus hijos que eso es un tema que a
veces hablamos de la migración como un
concepto no hay personas uno a uno son
personas que tienen vidas concretas no
entonces Es evidente pero en el caso de
ucranes que además eran refugiados
si hubiera habido una frontera
intermedia les hubieran como les
hubiéramos considerado refugiados igual
y esa es la diferencia Por qué Porque Es
evidente que existe una mayor afinidad
empatía esos racismo No yo sinceramente
creo que no o desde luego yo creo que
eso no movió la mayoría de las personas
la mayoría de las personas no son
racistas eh cuidado eh tienen problemas
después vivenciales también existen
problemas ahora ya en Polonia con por la
presencia durante mucho tiempo porque
por ejemplo pues daban trabajo más
barato que los polacos es decir los
problemas surgen en general la población
no es no es racista
de una composición distinta en el
sentido de que lo que llegaban
fundamentalmente eran mujeres con niños
y ancianos personas que no estaban en
edad militar Porque esos habían quedado
habían quedado dentro y por otra parte
es verdad que yo creo que la mayor parte
de los ucranianos Siempre han
manifestado su idea de que ellos lo que
quieren es volver y de hecho Se ha
producido un retorno
a Ucrania en cuanto las condiciones de
la guerra lo han permitido no pero bueno
Yo creo que es evidente que hay factores
como el de la cercanía el conocimiento
que condiciona la respuesta yo creo que
hay que huir de los dos extremos no del
discurso buenista que considera que en
fin no hay ningún problema y del
discurso catastrofista y xenófobo que
cree que Europa lo que tiene que ser es
una sociedad cerrada lo cual además es
imposible que los que están hay que
echarlos a todos porque creo que los dos
son dos grandes discursos impostores de
la realidad tanto el buenista como el
discurso como el discurso Xena fuego
dicho lo cual
Me parece que Europa no se puede
caracterizar como en general un
continente o un conjunto de sociedades
refractarias a la inmigración Me parece
que son hace justicia por lo que podemos
ver en nuestras en nuestras calles con
el paisaje urbano que se ha ido que se
ha ido desarrollando y que muestra cada
vez una mayor diversidad
elementos de tolerancia muy claramente
muy claramente establecidos y que yo
creo que lo que tenemos que hacer es que
desarrollarlos y fortalecerlos
respecto el pasado febrero los jefes
están de gobierno se reunieron a Cumbre
para hablar precisamente sobre migración
y se abrió por primera vez la
posibilidad de utilizar dinero europeo
para financiar muros y bayas Esto hace
poco era inconcebible está ganando el
discurso del miedo de que sin murallas
está la Unión Europea menos protegida
Bueno eso es una interpretación Yo creo
que es una interpretación más literaria
que política no bayas España ante una
valla importante en ceuta y en melilla y
yo creo que la protección física de las
fronteras me parece que es algo Bastante
natural en determinadas circunstancias
los jefes está el gobierno efectivamente
aprobaron eso luego curiosamente en el
parlamento ha habido disonancias cuando
ha habido que Reproducir esa votación y
y grupos pertenecientes a dirigidos por
jefes de estado de gobierno que en su
momento votaron a favor de esa de esa
propuesta Pues aquí votaron en contra en
una notable falta de falta de coherencia
no yo yo creo que
si el estado no cumple por sus
obligaciones principales y la obligación
una de las obligaciones fundamentales
del estado es la protección de las
fronteras que no significa que no entre
nadie yo en esas políticas de
inmigración cero no creo Me parece que
son destructivas y en el fondo son
grandes mentiras que se van que se van
implantando pues entonces lo que haremos
será alimentar ese discurso que ha
tenido tanto éxito entre los populismos
y que al final
se traslada a un discurso que tienes
desgraciadamente demasiados seguidores
probablemente en Europa y que considera
que la migración es únicamente un
problema
es un problema y es una oportunidad es
un desafío y es también parte de la
solución y si no vemos la inmigración en
todas sus dimensiones pues probablemente
seremos incapaces de adoptar una
estrategia adecuada
a la importancia del fenómeno yo sí me
permites yo a mí en general no me gusta
entrar en los debates
cuyo cuyo origen está muy condicionado
Hasta por las propias palabras y
expresiones que se utilizan no el
discurso de vallas y
y muros es un discurso con unas palabras
que tiene una connotación
las trompistas no la del muro con México
mire perdona Yo sí que quiero que Europa
financie las valles de melilla Pues
claro que sí obviamente y con más dinero
porque es frontera europea es necesario
además entonces entrar en ese marco de
no no se puede decir cómo que no se
tiene que financiar todo aquello que que
que que sirva para garantizar el control
de las fronteras por supuesto y a veces
eran vallas y a veces muros yo creo que
no no nadie va a construir aquí la
Muralla China para evitar entras Pero
porque realmente no sirve no es muy
costosa de mantener tiene una función a
veces más simbólica o más política que
otra cosa no Usted cree que ahora los
200 km de valla que está construyendo
Finlandia con Rusia va a impedir o
impediría a un grupo de blindados entrar
a Finlandia Pues sinceramente usted y yo
no es un mensaje político No usted
considera que esa valla que quiere
construir o Grecia o entre Grecia y
Turquía para los inmigrantes serviría
Bueno pero qué pasa Hay un problema que
siempre decimos no siempre decimos que
no hay que hacer pero nunca decimos que
hay que hacer Pues sabes lo que hay que
hacer intentar evitar que Turquía no
haga uso de la inmigración para
presionar a Grecia y a toda Europa lo
que no va a permitir es que Marruecos
utilice a personas para presionar
políticamente a España y a Europa es lo
que no hay que hacer pero cuando uno
permite que eso pase o deja que pase
desgraciadamente demasiado a menudo pues
tiene que tener mecanismos de control
Entonces virtualmente es necesario que
Europa con todos sus fronteras por
supuesto Por qué Porque así lo dicen las
legislaciones de los países europeos que
se tiene que controlar que son los que
tienen que encontrar las fronteras hay
fronteras europeas pero que las controla
son los estados Entonces es necesario en
ocasiones financiar mecanismos de
control en frontera para garantizar por
supuesto y estar armonizados en
ocasiones son vallas Sí el recinto me
llega hacerlo claro Entonces no entremos
en ese debate que en el fondo quiere
decir quiere prácticamente por encima la
mesa sobre la necesidad de que no se
persigue la inmigración ilegal y yo
sinceramente Considero que primero
regularla para que no sea ilegal Pero
por supuesto después la inmigración
ilegal hay que controlarla por supuesto
Y las entradas no controladas por
supuesto pero cuando yo he preguntado
una patera a España por Canarias o por
cualquier parte de la costa española o
por la pelusa o por o por Grecia yo no
sé quién viene ahí Oiga habrá que
controlar eso no O no entonces habrá que
tener mecanismos de control pero es muy
bonito cuando uno está según dónde
porque uno dice No hombre
como ejemplo eh problema de eso es que
los que hayan entrado entonces pero
ellos no tienen problema de entrada
ilegal por fronteras no gente que entra
y después tienen problemas de
convivencia no pero Carlos problemas los
tenemos los países mediterráneos Claro
sin duda creo que es muy bonito decir lo
que no hay que hacer dice Bueno entonces
cómo lo controlas esto qué vas a hacer
tú Cuando entras 10.000 personas
aumentaron en ceuta qué hacemos
Muchísimas gracias nos hemos quedado sin
tiempo Javier Jordi Gracias por vuestro
tiempo sé que es ajustado a ustedes les
esperamos en el próximo programa de de
Europa hoy Gracias por ver Francis 24 en
español
[Música]